the wind's expected to pick up tomorrow  the county has sent out reminders about  how to help cut down on your dust  exposure first limit your outdoor  exertion if you are heading out make  sure you're limiting the amount of time  don't do any heavy exercise for example  you're going to breathe heavier and  likely to inhale more particulates also  make sure you keep the windows closed  and doors closed don't want that dust  blowing inside your home not to mention  run your air conditioners both in your  home and also in the car that'll help  filter out the bad stuff and speaking of  that consider changing your air filters  to make sure they are fresh and up to  date there's also a number you can call  to report excessive amounts of dust  blowing in your area maybe from a  construction site even a vacant lot that  hotline number is 702-385-3878